congo na na na blaise la cbi minikos à
la interview nahio j'ai eu la chance de
jouer l'acteur quelques fois durant
matériel et me sens terrain parfois
obligés de nadia
[Musique]
mes parents sont
en volley et congolais voilà les deux
mon père est né au congo où ma mère et
mon beau là sont les tréteaux au
concours maisons garder leur assise non
relais ce parce que grands parents
étaient étaient originaires de l'angola
c'est pour ça que je dis souvent que je
suis les deux parce que je pour moi
c'est ça commence
je ne parle pas au quotidien mais mais
c'est sûr que je peux parfois entamé des
discussions en lingala est moment ça
peut m'arriver je pense que c'est
important de connaître les origines ses
cultures et change en suisse hier
là je ne sais pas si tu vas comprendre
combinant des eisa plaisent
la cp les mimiques haut salat interview
maillot
socgen a dit rare diamant
c'est vrai ça vient d'où e
ça vient de mon ancien entraîneur quand
j'étais tout petit j'ai connu à
vincennes et qui marque les entrées
aliyev clairefontaine
voilà c'était un peu mon mentor quand
j'étais petit et c'est lui qui m'a
appelé comme ça j'étais un peu son
chouchou et donc que du coup mes
collègues à l'époque chambrer un peu pas
pour à ça et c'est pour ça qu'au 6 maps
l'église on faisait un peu plus ce
plaisir est un peu comme ça quoi
toujours jusqu'à la fin je suis
quelqu'un qui lâchent rien et importe où
je suis je suis venu en mls pour pour
gagner des trophées aussi donc oui je
reste je reste un chat roux
c'est faux
c'est faux ça j'aurais pas et j'en
aurais pas eu les capacités un sacré
boulot je pense qu'il ya beaucoup comme
je l'aï dit à beaucoup de travail
derrière derrière cela d'études et je
leur tire mon chapeau parce que ça va
passer tous les jours et parfois de la
réussite et parfois voilà il ya des
drames si c'est un métier que j'admire
mais je ne pense pas que j'aurai la
force moi de pouvoir en être
le fait justement d'être une personne
qui puisse sauver des vies pour moi
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
et ça c'est pas moins dû au fait que
j'ai pu rencontrer des gens c'est ce que
je vois tous les jours si j'aime pas
trop ce terme là mais on à vrai dire on
se remet juste derrière emballante
réguler mais bon après c'est pas c'est
pas juste ça mais parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de travail derrière
mais que je pense que ces gens là voient
la saison un rôle très important dans la
vie de tous les jours et je pense que
quoi de de les valoriser plus qu'ils ne
le sont aujourd'hui
et c'est pour ça que je je tenais à
faire cette compagnie justement pour les
mettre en valeur chaque jour sauvent des
vies en risquant à l'heure alors
supportons d
non je pense quoi je pense pas je suis
pas assez basses et acteurs pour fable
et on sait jamais pourquoi pas tu es une
belle expérience
c'est une bonne expérience bon j'ai eu
la chance de jouer l'acteur quelques
fois dehors du rhum intérieure mais et
me sort terrain pour fois un métier
aussi
je le découvre aussi réclament un ma
première fille qui est le sial souhait
d'être actrice donc aux médias
oui pour ma part oui parce que
aujourd'hui ggd formidable enfants j'ai
une formidable famille et je peux dire
qu'à ce niveau là ouais c j'ai vidé mon
extraordinaire avec mes enfants à 20 ans
ça m'arrivait de passer parfois des
nuits blanches un même si eux mais 22
ans et un entraîneur ont pas ou pas
l'accepter ouais ou pas aimé entendre ça
mais ouais ça m'était déjà arrivé
décerner une nuit blanche et d'arrivée
allemande m'a entraînée comme il se doit
j'avais la force
aujourd'hui c'est que tu peux faire ça
oui c'est un spa g mi temps je suis
malgré mes 30 ans enfin malgré la
trentaine j'ai encore plus que trente
ans mais je suis java est encore
d'actualité et je suis n'est pas de la
nouvelle génération au but existent à
l'heure j'ai dit j'ai des enfants
nantais la première a déjà 12 ans est
déjà connecté
malheureusement et donc d'autres faut
essayer de rester à la page de ce bon
papa t'es plus à la page et faire une
confidence j'ai essayé en confinement tu
vois on essaie de se couper des choses à
faire et donc on est ce m ha tik tok
mais j'ai vite lâché coup c'est pas
possible il faut passer neuf ans j'ai
pas mais voilà capacités il faut être un
très bon acteur et j'en suis pas encore
oui même si même et je pense que samuel
eto'o et didier drogba ont fait aussi
bien
une très grande carrière mais c'est vrai
que mister jo je sais c'est vraiment
costaud ce qu'il a fait ouais ouais on
ne peut dire on peut dire que ça reste
une très grande légende du football
africain et même mondial parce qu'il a
obtenu le ballon d'or
ça déborde le quotidien fait par mois un
moment où ses meilleurs fils thibault
c'est sûr
et plus que l'avc moi c'est une ville
extraordinaire j'ai adoré et honnêtement
je suis même en train de penser de moi
de faire ma vie ici parce que parce que
j'ai tout quoi de ma famille c'est
porteur se porte bien ici on a le beau
temps toute l'année on s'est fait des
amis
les enfants se font des amis de toutes
cultures de tout horizon et donc où elle
arrive à s'ouvrir et et puis moi pareil
non travaillées mais même pour l'après
carrière donc voilà j'ai tout et tout
est réuni pour que pour que je puisse
continuer à bien vivre ici et même si
bien sûr ma famille me manque aussi et
que de temps en temps ça me plairait de
retourner les voir mais mais de vivre
sur quotidien mais ça me plaît